i think that
the prison case was a wake-up call
coming a little too late for many meps
who say america's whole scale harvesting
of personal data as in the recently
blown prism scandal has been happening
for years despite assurances of laws
protecting europeans as well as if not
better than the u.s protects its own
some meps called for more the americans
or any other country is going to take as
much space as we will let them
so it is all about the european union
showing a bit more backbone and telling
where the limits are
in a crisis it's a welcome lifeline for
a million workers are posting abroad but
still within the eu
however abuse by companies of workers
rights legal confusion and red tape are
hampering opportunities and constricting
free movement of people and labor if
this movement will reduce 700 000 of
people from western europe will lose
their job and 300 from eastern europe so
i think this is very dangerous
a lengthy inquiry into whether hundreds
of new laws in hungary breach eu
fundamental rights including freedom of
expression and minority rights has wound
up with meps demanding the right-wing
government of victor orban fall behind
eu values
a blow for hungarian nationalists a
right and proper step according to the
mep leading the inquiry we had enough
of control of punishment of humiliation
and we want more sovereignty more
independence and united we shall take
our homeland back i've had
many messages hundreds of messages from
hungarian citizens what they tell me is
that they want the european union to
defend their rights after 89 the promise
that we europeans made to one another is
that we will never again abandon our
european brothers and sisters if there
are problems with their fundamental
rights rule of law and democracy